[Musique]
robert gaubert est un enfant de la butte
aux cailles à paris
fils d'artisan juifs arrivés en france
dans les années 30 il avait un ami
d'enfance qui habitaient en face de la
boutique de ses parents et ça plaît
henri bec
m attendait devant l'épicerie
en général on y aille qu'on s'attendait
pas mais le jour où on a mille étoiles
jaunes il savait que je n'avais que je
vais et il préférait qu'on soit 2 et on
est arrivés ensemble à l'école avec
l'étoile jaune comme c'était un quartier
où il y avait beaucoup moins de juifs
que dans le 11ème dans 20e et c'est y
pas très nombreux dans votre classe ce2
avec il y avait que 2 juillet que lui et
moi
si henry becque survie au port de
l'étoile imposée aux juifs fin mai 1942
il n'échappe pas aux rafles de juillet
ni à la déportation comme douze autres
élèves de l'école rue du moulin des
prêts
sa disparition a inspiré un livre à
robert gaubert où le narrateur berg
s'adresse à son ami bec bect s'est pas
imposé comme une idée l'aimé comme une
présence
et
je me suis dit si je lui écris c'est
d'une certaine manière non pas de le
rendre vivant mais présent
de toute façon il faut que je continue
de décrire et ce n'est pas parce que tu
ne répondra pas que l'histoire va devoir
se passer de toi
gardons-nous notre métier
[Musique]
henri beecke aurait pu rester à un nom
dans un livre si son histoire n'avait
pas resurgi dans le quartier de la butte
aux cailles
en janvier 2020 son nom est de nouveau
affiché à l'adresse où sa famille et lui
habitait
alors voilà c'est à peu près ici qu
était cette affichette apposée par
l'union des étudiants juifs de france
uejf et lorsque j'ai vu que ses deux
enfants
à cette adresse avait été arrêté déporté
ça m'a ému touché interpellé et ça m'a
conduit à faire des recherches sur ce
rush luc lansaman
pendant deux ans michel horn ne récolte
de nombreuses archives au mémorial de la
shoah au ministère de la défense à la
ville de paris et retrace le parcours de
cette famille composée de deux parents
est de 4 fils
d'une famille qui a fui lé
l'antisémitisme la misère qu'il y avait
en pologne à la quitter une petite ville
qui s'appelait krasnik sont venus en
france parce qu'ils espéraient une vie
nouvelle avait dans un pays où les les
juifs avaient les mêmes droits que
n'importe quel habitant du pays et
finalement ils ont été arrêtés raflés
par des policiers français ils ont été
exterminés en pologne dans un camp qui
se situé à quelques kilomètres de la
ville d'où il venait
mais grâce à ses recherches
michel découvre qu'en y avait une soeur
de 26 ans qui a quitté paris une semaine
avant la rafle du vel d'hiv
avec son fils elle rejoint son mari à
légionnaires démobilisés à marseille
pendant deux ans ils vivent sans
encombre dans la cité phocéenne jusqu'à
ce que la milice les rattrape
jacques le neveu d'henry becque se
souvient nous avons nous c'est à dire
mon père ma mère et moi qui à l'époque
était enceinte de ma soeur avant été
arrêté le 27 mai 1944 sur dénonciation
de la concierge de l'immeuble
mon père a été déporté et on l'a plus
jamais revu et ma mère et moi on a été
interné dans le quartier des consignes
et de l'hôpital de la conception à
marseille
jacques sa mère et sa soeur née en
prison sont encore en vie quand
marseille délibéré trois mois plus tard
mais jacques n'aime pas trop ce rap et
de cette période ni des photos garder
précieusement par sa mère
je sais qu'elles sont là je sais que je
peux les voir quand j'en ai envie je ne
regarde pas souvent
parmi ces clichés celui de deux petits
garçons eh bien on voit mon oncle henri
qui a 11 12 ans et puis moi qui ai
deux ans ou presque deux ans
ces photos sont venus compléter les
découvertes de michel horn
quand il a réussi à retrouver les
descendants de la famille beck l'an
passé ce que m'a appris michel m'a
permis de m'ancrer de m'agripper à
quelques informations qui me situe dans
l'espace et dans le temps je suis moins
flottant qu'auparavant
le 25 janvier dernier
grâce aux efforts de michel horn une
plaque a été dévoilée à l'adresse où la
famille beck a été raflée à paris
à cette occasion jacques baudat a
rencontré robert gaubert et lui a remis
une photo de henry son ami d'enfance
que 80 ans après 80
les nouvelles photos de bec
je pourrais pas parler parce que ça me
met encore
armand
voir son visage son paysage enfants
[Musique]
e